hello and welcome to my presentation
about validation of i.t
systems in the regulated industries my
name is siri siegelstad
i've been working with practical
validation of i.t systems in regulated
industries
for and also with limbs for more than 30
years
i have included a few pictures from my
home country norway
in case you wonder where they are from
and i hope you will enjoy them
the validation definitions are slightly
different from different
uh standards the iso 17025
says that validation is the confirmation
by examination
and the provisions of objective evidence
that a particular requirement
for a specific intended use are
fulfilled
the u.s food and drugs administration
says
uh that validation is defined as
establishing documented evidence which
provides a high degree of assurance that
a specific process
will consistently produce a product
meeting its predetermined specifications
and
quality attributes while it seems like
these two definitions are different i
think they basically say the same
one talks about the objective evidence
and the other about documented evidence
the underlines there they are mine i
will now
talk about how to validate i.t systems
regardless of which standard you have to
comply with
why validate the standards state that
validation of your processes are needed
i.t systems are part of these processes
however the more important issue is not
actually what the standards say
and the requirements are but the fact
that you need to understand your
processes
and trust the system to maintain your
data integrity
so what if we don't validate for pharma
regulating bodies like the fda can deny
us to send the products to the market
other labs like contract labs or
calibration labs may lose their
accreditation
and regardless what industry you're in
the consequences are big
validation must be done on site by the
users
you cannot buy a validated system
testing does not replace built-in
quality
validation must be performed before the
system is taken into real use and
continued
throughout the system's lifecycle
the good thing and the bad thing is that
the extent of the validation is defined
by the users
regardless of which standard applies
it's totally the end user's
responsibility to validate his system
that is on his site on his platform
as implemented in his company and as
used in his organization
so which requirements apply
that depends on the industry and on the
market for pharma it's the gxps that
apply
gxp has good manufacturing practice good
laboratory practice
and good clinical practice additionally
if you send the products to the u.s
market you have to comply with
the 21 cfr part 11 which covers
electronic data and electronic
signatures
if you send to the eu market you have to
comply with the eu equivalent of the 21
cfr part 11
namely the gmp nx11
iso 17025 gives a global accreditation
additionally you need to have
your own quality system internally in
your organization
and that is regardless of the standard
that you're using
validation of the ig systems may be a
challenge
we're trained as scientists and
understand the chemistry biology
processes analytical methods etc that we
work on
on a daily basis we're not trained the
same way
with it systems because the i.t systems
are just
tools to help us do our work we need to
understand what the i.t
systems do in order to understand how to
handle them
fortunately we don't really need to know
anything about programming in order to
do this
validation is a large job and may be
made somewhat easier by dividing the
tasks into smaller pieces
these pieces may be the dq iq
oqpq approach of the gxp and gamp
and i will explain this later or
it could be any other suitable division
earlier it was more common to test the
final system to see that it worked okay
and that was sufficient
today the life cycle approach is the
only acceptable way of doing anything
life cycle is to make sure that you have
control over the whole
process from conception of the i.t
system to the retirement
and the conception is the vendor's
responsibility so that makes it a little
bit more difficult
standards have different informations
and can be useful to read
even if you don't have to comply with
that particular standard so that's one
place to get help
the other places could be gamp5 which
i'm going to cover
it could be books that are available
classes
training conferences at least not in
this
covet 19 uh
you could also get some help from
consultants but regardless
of how you do it you need to be a part
of it yourself because you are
ultimately responsible in your
organization
regardless of who have actually done it
now gamp good automated manufacturing
practice
in my opinion it's the best tool there
is regardless of the industry
camp started in 1991 to explain what to
do with the it systems in the
pharmaceutical industry
now is in its fifth version hence damp
5. there are additional guidelines and
books for risk-based approach to
compliant electronic records and
signatures
validation of computerized laboratory
systems
technic testing of critical systems and
several more references in the guidebook
gamp is also very useful even if you're
not in the pharmaceutical industry
according to gaap there are five
software categories
category one is infrastructure software
uh category two is no longer in use
but it's still there uh category three
is non-configured products category four
configured products and category five
custom applications
in this presentation i will only go
through category four as that is what
lims is
limits may however also include custom
built or so called bespoke
software for your organization and that
software will have to be treated as
category 5.
so the category 4 is configured products
and this is defined as software often
very complex
that can be configured by the user to
meet the specif
specific needs of the user's business
process
the software code is not altered
examples are laboratory information
management systems
lims data supervisory control and data
acquisition systems
various manufacturing enterprise systems
electronic document
management systems etc
validation of the category 4
is starts with a conception
of the system that is the vendor's
job and it continues with our job as
users with
selection of the system installation
implementation
testing and finally maintaining the
system in a validated state
by complying with procedures for the
system
the gap 5 approach is first we do a risk
management
to decide how important the system is in
the process
this can be used you can use camp 5 or
the risk guide for that
you decide what category of software
to decide what needs to be done and you
can find more information about that in
game five
then you will combine the risks and
categories to decide what to do with
this specific system
there's also a testing guide that
will help you find out how to test the
system
risk assessments requirements for
records in the gxp
regulations are also relevant for the
other standards like 17025
and product quality also includes lab
results from
an accredited lab
the potential impact the records on
patient safety
is of course a high risk
and uh also uh impact on records on
products and services for the iso 17025
generally using three classification
levels high which could cover cleaning
deviation and investigation
batch records medium training
calibration approvals and authorization
and low could be planning documents
we can manage the identified risks in
several different ways
modifying the process the process may be
any process in production laboratory i.t
system
and by changing the process the risk may
in some cases be less
than when the original process is used
we can modify the system design and the
system design is about the i.t system
we can apply technical controls and
those may for
example be that fewer people have access
to important functions in the system
for example approvals modifications of
static data or user access
and finally the last resort is the
procedural controls
this is if it's not possible to make
technical changes to the process
system or technical control the
procedures
or standard operating procedures can
tell what is allowed and what is not
allowed
the problem with the procedures is that
people may follow them or not
new understanding of the processes make
it possible to see
other or different or previously
unrecognized
risks or to assess the existing risk
differently so we need to monitor the
effectiveness of the controls
we'll verify that the controls are
effective consider if
unrecognized hazards are present
if the estimated risk is different if
the original assessment is still valid
and this will feed back into the risk
management
when controls have been added the risks
should be less than they were before the
controls
but we need to reassess the risk to show
the current state
and document that and the assessment
should of course feed back into the risk
management
in order to effectively manage the risks
now again 5 has this really
large form for describing
responsibilities between the supplier
and the user
we're not going through this in detail
but please note that you may
leverage the supplier involvement it's
close to the bottom there meaning that
you do not have to repeat what he has
already done
terminology
is the still the most common terminology
for the validation purposes
is the dq iq oqpq concept from gamp4
and even if this terminology has been
changed to verification activities in
gamb5
you decide which terminology you want to
use and you define that terminology in
your organization
terminology varies between standards and
also from company to company and this is
perfectly acceptable
as long as you define your terminology
and
stick to your definitions
this is my model for it systems
validation
the green arrows down going from top to
bottom
are what you in the user organization is
responsible for
when you are validating your system
if you look at the top dq green arrow
there you will find dq iq oqpq
and those are the vendors
responsibilities because the vendor has
developed a system
our job is to check in our d2 that this
has been done
in a quality environment
now the brown arrows down in the pq
which are called the items there
they are new or changed analytical
method sample type specifications
instruments etc inside our system
these need to be validated also and
that's also
often done in the pq or post pq period
i will be going through the validation
plan in detail as this forms the outline
for your system validation so the next
quite a few slides will cover that and i
will tell you when
i'm at the bottom of the validation plan
first of all can some information be
found
elsewhere if you have information found
in other documents in your organization
they shall be referred to or hyperlinked
to and not repeated in your validation
plan
and the reason for that is that it is
impossible to keep repeated intro
updated everywhere so make your
reference at the
list at the end of the document with
document name id
versions and dates for the references
the first pages of the plan are
according to your normal requirements
for documents i will let you read it and
refer to it later
and i will skip the details here and you
will
also have to look into your
company's organization companies
procedures to see what you
really need in your plan
the same goes for this page really
in the validation plan we need to
describe how to handle errors and
corrective actions preventive actions
also called kappa
we will describe how to handle errors
during the validation period
and you may have an error handling sop
but following that may be tedious and
not really necessary
for a system that is not yet in
production
so how we can do is that we describe
something
in the validation plan
kappa for internal matters like errors
in the hardware or software
user errors or implementation errors
we need to plan the correct correction
if appropriate we need to correct the
errors
to document how the correction has been
done
revalidate or retest when possible or is
appropriate
report the corrective actions and
revalidation results
approve it and or authorizing authorize
it
and then create a preventive action and
approving
and authorizing this okay
so another example is that you will have
to define if the problem is solved
uh when the next version of the system
is released
maybe a year from now or maybe you have
received an acknowledgement from the
supplier
that is if you find system errors
the validation plan also needs to
cover acceptance criteria they are
predefined in the validation plan
it's easy to write that we do not accept
any errors and
no errors if the result desired outcome
but it is kind of difficult to live with
as we usually do find some
errors it's also impossible to foresee
which errors you will find and to
discuss or rate them up front
instead you can define a score system
for serious errors
medium errors and we can live with this
errors
and have that defined in the validation
plan with scores you can set up a
calculation for what the acceptance
criteria
can be it could be like a total score
add all the error scores
number of serious errors number of
medium errors
combination of this like a total score
of so much
and not more than so much of type
whatever errors
remember also that each error may be
found more than once
but it will only be counted once
the validation plan describes the phases
it describes defines the phase with the
input during and the output
describes in which order each of the
validation activities shall be done as
this is not really obvious in the model
i showed you
for example some pq items may have to be
done during the
dq iq or oq phase etc
in this presentation i want to focus on
the dqiq oqpq
faces and that is because
these are the most well-known
terminology that we use you may of
course use any model or any type of
phases
or even no faces as long as they're
defined and described
and adhered to
the overview of the faces you will have
a face name
you will have definition prerequisites
for the start of the face
input to the face what to do during the
phase
and what's the outcome of the phase
so we'll start with the first one and
that's the development qualification
the development qualification shall
ensure that the software has been
developed in a structured way
in a quality environment so the dq
inputs would be project proposal
approval start of the project for the
new i.t system
uh and if you have some guidelines and
sops for this type of work
that is of course also something that
needs to be taken into consideration
now i like to make a three-phase
dq and i think the dq has several
distinctive tasks
so that's why i call them dq one two and
three
as you can see the faces are partly
overlapping but i think they still make
sense
the dq one is to use the requirement
specification
the assessment of the vendor's answers
to the requirement specification
and then the contract
the dq2 would be to audit the top vendor
and that of course needs to come
before the contract if you decide to
audit the top vendor
or the top vendors the dq3
is the implementation functional and
design specification
and the dq one and two are before we
make the decision to buy the system
whereas the dq3
is the implementation which of course is
after we've decided to buy this
particular system
the output of the dq phase is that we
will have a well
created system in a quality environment
by the supplier or
vendor whatever you want to call them a
correctly configured system for the
company's use
a system description and a dq report
the dq report will refer to other
documents like the supplier audit report
functional specification the user
requirement specification
and will not repeat the content
the iq installation qualification
shall ensure that the hardware and the
software are installed properly and that
installation works according to the
intentions
the iq is by far the quickest of the
phases
we basically need to keep track of all
hardware software and the choices
selected when the system is installed
there will eventually be more than one
instance of the database
we generally have a sandbox database
where we play around
trying to find out how to do things and
this is not under any type of control
the implementation or and or validation
instance
where we implement the system this needs
to be under control
we also use this for validating the
system itself and the implemented and
configured data
when the configured data has been
validated we can move this to the light
instance so that
can be used then we have the light
database instance
that is a controlled copy of the
validation instance
this is used in the lab for real data
we may also have a possible training
instance where we train
people this is often a copy of the
implementation or live database
it does not have to be under control and
the users can play with it during the
training
the input to the iq is the installation
guideline
if we have any an sop for installation
manuals for the system and what we're
doing during the
iq phase is do we start the system and
configuration management
we start the system backup procedures we
have an installation test plan
and we do the installation test testing
and the output
is the installation report
the operation qualification oq will
ensure that the system
operates according to the intention
stated in the functional specification
which is directly derived from the user
requirement specification the urs
the it is a control that the system
functions the way it has been written
and implemented for the company
the input to the oq phase is the
system functional and design
specification
the iq documents if we have a guideline
we will have that what we do during the
oq phase is to have
plans including the test plan
we have the test records and the output
is the oq
report
then there is the performance or process
qualification the pq
that will show that the system performs
according to the business intentions in
the company's environment
the phase will also ensure that the
system will continue to be in a
validated state
after it has been taken into use
now there are two ways of defining pq
the pq phase finishes when the system is
authorized for live use
or we can let the pq phase never finish
it's ongoing validation and activities
until retirement
but for validation purposes we usually
let the process or performance
qualification finish when the system
validation has been closed off
however we need also to ensure that we
have ongoing validation activities for
the rest of the time we use the system
and i will get back to that little later
and the pq input will be the system
functional and design specification
the iq and oq documents and if we have a
guideline
for life cycle that would also be an
input
what we create during the phase is the
pq plan
including the test class we create the
test records and we have a pq report as
the outcome
for all but it is possible to
have oq and pq separately or in one
phase
and the question is what do we want to
do
in my opinion for all practical purposes
it's actually better to combine the oq
and the pq
we're going to test each of the
functions anyway in the oq
and they might just as well be tested
inside the workflow
pq where we're using them but it is for
you to make the decision in your
organization
i know of at least one organization with
the sop
system where they have strictly divided
these two phases and that caused a lot
of extra work for them because they
really had to retest a lot of the
functions from the oq also in the pq
i will talk a little bit more about this
later in the presentation but this
is the end of the validation plan now
we'll go on
i'll talk more about each of the
qualifications
or actually not each of them but more
like
what you do we do with all of the
qualifications
all of them will include writing the
qualification plan
what to do how to do it who will do it
we'll follow the plan and test according
to the plan
we will create test documentation during
the testing and we will write about a
qualification report
as with the validation plan the first
pages are according to your normal
requirements for documents and i will
let you read this and refer to it later
and skip the details
the qualification plan details will be
a plan for what to do write it up or
refer to other documents
plan for how to do it including the
sequence and the task
the test plans will have identification
for each of the items
what to do in detail expected results
room for making notes and signatures
during the testing
and we may also have
references to the user requirement
specification or functional
specification is appropriate that's
called traceability
we will also include the acceptance
criteria
the test documentation we will document
while
we are testing it could be done paper or
electronically
we'll mark pass and fail while we are
testing
and also we will create as much
documentation as possible it could be
printouts
reports screen prints comments
and we will sign in data after testing
and of course save all the documentation
this is just a few lines of real test
plan so you can see how i like to write
the test claim
however it's perfectly okay for you to
do it totally differently
this contains a column with a reference
it has a column with what to do a column
for expected results
it has room for comments and links to
additional documentation
and it has links to the user requirement
specification or functional
specification
this is often called a traceability
matrix
one may also want or instead want to
create
a separate document as the traceability
matrix between the user requirement
specification
the functional specification and the
testing itself
this will give a better overview and if
you are using excel
it can be sorted in various ways
b okay
the qualification report
there are some requirements for that do
not
repeat the plan do not repeat the
results
focus on the conclusions discuss the
errors that have been found
and set if the testing has met the
acceptance criteria
keep it short
as we go along in the process we
generally have a string of events where
one is dependent on the previous
when one qualification report is
authorized this will usually be the
prerequisite for a go for the next phase
so dq will have to be finished before
the iq and the same with the iq before
the oqpq
when all of these qualification reports
have been done
we will write the validation report
summarizing up the whole validation
and i will get back to that
system testing is iq and oq together
this is one suggestion for how to do
this
system testing often comprises oq and
parts of pq
oq testing is checking that each command
or function works as it's supposed to do
this is
very often tested by the supplier as
well
and if we have access to that then
we don't need to do all the same testing
the pq is testing that these commands or
functions work
well in the workflow that we have in our
organization
we can test these together if
your quality system allows it
workflow tests are created based on the
workflow described in the user
requirement specification
and if the user requirement
specification does not exist
it is not possible to test it because
you have the questions
but you do not have the expected answers
your workflow which is how you want to
use the system in your organization
needs to be tested even if your
functions oq
have been tested by the supplier or by
your company separately
the process qualification is the
workflow in the system it could be
something like this
or it could be something totally
different hours maybe
variations of that depending on on what
you are testing
but anyway it needs to be described and
you need to test it
you also need to test not only
everything goes right but also test
whatever happens when something goes
wrong
the testing itself
actually the testing itself does not
take an awful lot of time if it has been
properly planned
and then the job goes smoothly
if everybody knows what they are going
to do and they know who is going to
test the next part of it then it will be
done relatively quickly even if there
are pretty complex
testing regimes
the validation report
the validation report is the conclusion
of the validation
when i write the report i like to start
with the validation
plan and change that to create the
report for example
when the requirement in the validation
plan is that we shall create for example
the oqp2 plan
i will enter the reference to that plan
i also entered a reference to all of the
other qualification plans
reports etc to all the sops and other
documents that we have created in the
process
so the validation report will sum up the
validation activities from the different
phases
does not repeat the plan and the results
focus on the conclusion discuss the
errors that have been found
and stated the testing method acceptance
criteria
quality assurance persons sign it off
meaning that the system can now be used
live
sops for each system now if you want to
keep the system in a validated state we
need to have it under
somewhat something close to a complete
control
this can best be done by having standard
operating procedures or sops
for the system there's a long list of
sops
to keep a large system like limps and a
validated safe at all times
i do not have time to go through the
detailed content on this list but
more information on each sop can be
found in the book that i've written
and there will be a reference at the end
here
as with all quality documents sops will
need to have reference
to each other instead of repeating the
same information
i will talk a little bit about some of
these slps
we have access to the system who shall
have
access who shall give the access
and how shall it be reassessed but
i think the most frequently forgotten
thing in the access sop is that
withdrawal of accidents
it is extremely important to make sure
that a disgruntled terminated employee
cannot access or do damage to the data
at the same day as he or she is leaving
the company
so make sure that you have a procedure
that will
terminate also his ex or his or her
access
change control error handling with kappa
change control and revalidation are
closely linked
we need to have change control all the
way through the life cycle
and changes shall be evaluated for
consequences before
implemented otherwise we will have some
really
fun or not so fun things going on
changes in plans require changes in
testing
all changes and evaluations must be
documented and all revisions must be
available
a little bit about the change control in
detail
what do we do uh how and who can suggest
changes who can receive the change
request and how shall it be documented
how shall the change be assessed and by
whom and the impact of the assessment
how shall that be documented
or assessed for that matter
what if the request is turned down can
they request to get a second opinion
depending on the assessment how shall
change be handled
and how shall change be documented we
also need
an sop for configuration management
now those are a couple of different
things of configuration management one
is
the internal data in the system which
static data or template data need to be
under configuration management
which dynamic data or daily use data
need to be
under configuration management if we
need to have any at all
how should this be carried out who can
change configuration and how shall it be
documented
but we also have configuration
management outside of the system itself
we need a configuration management of
the servers
and clients and other hardware network
the software the operating system
database system
and the system itself the
fda has required that we plan for
decommissioning
and i personally think it's kind of like
planning the funeral when the baby has
not yet been born
so what i usually like to do is that to
write
the sop as required stating that when
the system is ready for retirement plans
must be made for
decommissioning and for how to preserve
the data in the system
if a new system shall be shall replace
the current one the process must follow
the current procurement as a piece
now we have planned it and documented
and we have not said a single thing
about it
we also need sops for daily use
for a large system like a lymph system
this
probably should be divided into several
slps each with their own targets and the
targets could be user groups
products labs organization parts or
whatever is most appropriate in your
organization
what does this sop cover
what information shall be entered and
where in the system
are there mandatory and optional entries
workflows
or whatever is appropriate do not
include how things shall be done because
the users are expected to be trained and
if you state that we will use the top
left menu go down three phases and press
that button and go down to
next menu then you are in a
lot of problem whenever the system is
being updated so expect the users to
know how to do this
use the system but they need to know
where where the information
shall be and also
there needs to be references to other
sops for the daily use if there are more
than one
disaster recovery and business
continuity are actually two aspects of
the same issue
disaster recovery the general the it
department's job to fix the problems
provide that the building hasn't burned
down or
been broken by an earthquake or
something whereas the business
continuity
is the user organization's job how do we
work
when the system is not up and running
to have those plans is one thing but you
really really need to test the disaster
recovery plans and the business
continuity plans
document the testing and what happened
during the testing and make the report
because it is
too late to do it when you need it and
it doesn't work
the sop for error handling would cover
definitions of errors who can report
an error and how is this done who shall
receive
an error report
how shall it be documented how to assess
them
how serious are they and what the impact
etc
all this needs to be defined
how shall we handle it and that of
course depends on the assessment and
finally the kappa corrective actions
preventive actions
which prevented actions are needed to
avoid the error being repeated
that could be for example updates of an
sop
i talked about earlier that we might
have more than one instance of the lims
database
we need at least the sandbox
and the we may need the training these
are largely uncontrolled
but we also need at least two controlled
instances the validation or testing
instance
for an implementation instance for
testing
and then the production or live instance
they both
need to be under control
now remember the validation model in the
beginning uh
this is about the brown arrows inside
the pq
we need to qualify the static data in
the system and this
can be done independently of validating
the system itself
because we continuously add
data or change static data we add new
analytical methods new specifications
we change analytical methods we change
products
etc and these need to be qualified or
validated
to see that it has been entered
correctly and can be used as planned
so it is possible to
include the various test plans inside
the sops maybe as appendix or something
this means that the test plans are
pre-approved that could
be useful
we also need the sop to this uh to
explain
how what data needs formal
qualifications and how shall it be
qualified
the sop for static data
may want to include screen prints that
show all the fields and explain each of
the fields
now again that might be a problem if
an update of the system makes it
different but what is important is to
describe
which fields are mandatory and which
fields are optional
which rules distinguish between those
so i said exactly what shall be entered
including naming conventions
and nomenclatures state exactly how to
name these fields
the naming must be consistent in order
to be able to compare
the data and i can tell you that when
i implemented a lymph system in the late
80s in the company that i
used to work for we realized that
there were 12 different ways of writing
weight weight percent
12 different ways as
readers we understand that the w before
or after percent
or upper lower case or even space or no
space between those
w's and this and the percent are the
same but the system does not
so the result was that with 12 different
ways of writing weight weight percent
11 had to be changed and 11 groups of
people were unhappy about this
darn limb system that did not uh
right weight weight percent the way they
wanted it to
uh whether we have the system
description in an sop
or we just have it as a system
description is really up to
each of the organization's
suggestions but we need an
overview of the processes where the
system is being used
we need the main data and electronic
records
diagrammic overview of the system
software hardware i.t infrastructure
interface to other systems and which
data is moved to and from these systems
locations of the systems and operation
and maintenance
strategy
we also need to describe
responsibilities for the system
owner operation administration
maintenance
could be named departments or roles but
not named individuals
how and when shall the description be
updated
reference to other sops configuration
management
generic sop generic system description
sorry
training is an important part
the linux users or the system users need
to be trained
and the sop will explain a little bit
about that
how shall who be notified when somebody
needs training
and how much training does each of the
different types of users
need based on their roles in the system
who's responsible for providing training
and what shall be included in training
like theory and practice
a new role new training how training is
documented in training records
tvs etc
i know this has been a lot of
information and
it is a lot more to learn
in a lab i visited at some point i found
this stating that
theory is you know everything but
nothing works
practices everything works but you do
not know why
and we in our lab combine theory and
practice
nothing works and nobody knows why
however i think that in a quality
assured lab
they combined theory and practice in a
totally different way everything works
and everybody knows why and that is the
goal for us
i have written a book uh called
international i.t
regulations and compliance and you will
know this
covers the quality management system
with emphasis on the i.t
system has a large chapter on
instruments in the lab and
large chapter limbs
and here is my contact information and
you're welcome to
contact me if you are interested
oh i got this wrong i did not
click on the slides on the show there
could be
could we go back a little bit
yes to what side are you going to go
back to
yeah i'll find the number here um
uh go back to slide 83
is that the last one you saw
yes theory in practice right and we can
take it slide
84.
however i think that a quality assured
lab combines theory and practice in a
totally different way
everything works and everybody knows why
this concludes my
very very short presentation on
the validation of i.t systems
if you are interested in reading a
little bit more i have written a book
called international iq regulations and
compliance
this covers a lot of different standards
a quality management system with these
emphasis on i.t systems
it has a large chapter on instruments in
the lab and a large chapter on limb
and also here is my contact information
in case you want to contact me and
you're certainly welcome to do so
thank you very much for listening to me